[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to a video
that i'm very very excited about it's
been right about three weeks on the nose
since the 2022 candidates tournament
finished janet pomnishi as most of you
probably know
won in absolutely crushing fashion he
secured tournament victory with a round
to spare and
the winner of the candidates of course
gets the right to challenge
uh the world champion in the next world
championship match which ian has already
done now the candidates has been
entirely overshadowed by shocking news
or maybe not so shocking news depending
on where you stood that magnus carlson
has renounced
uh his willingness to
defend his world championship title
which means that jan will be facing off
against dingley wren the second place
finisher in the candidates tournament in
the next world championship match but
my biggest pet peeve is that when these
news come out and when a tournament like
the candidates finishes there's often
uh you know a couple of days where you
see immediate reactions and you see
people going crazy and congratulating
yan what you see less of is a
substantive analysis of how exactly
yanupanishi won the candidates how do
you do that what are the skills that yon
displayed in the 2022 candidates that
the other incredibly strong competitors
did not display
to the same level and that is the
subject of today's video i've done a lot
of work on jan's incredible candidates
performance and i'm very excited to
share my findings with you these next 40
45 minutes we are going to delve very
deep as deep as we can possibly delve
into the root causes of yon nipponeshi's
victory at the candidates tournament now
i could talk about this for hours
so
i'm going to try to hit on the most
important points and at the end of the
video i hope that you will have a better
understanding of what exactly makes yon
upanishing tick and why he is such an
exciting player to watch and why he
performs so incredibly well specifically
at the candidates
now
the first thing that we're going to do
is
i'm going to present to you some stats
that i researched in preparation for the
video so the first thing that i did
is i tried to determine at which point
in the games jan did most of the winning
now he won five games out of 14 and he
drew the rest so the first thing i did
was that i ran all of the the games
through an engine
and i built
a a little graph now this is very
amateurish so please uh please forgive
the technical quality of this but i
think you'll be able to read the numbers
uh i ran each game with an engine
and i uh sort of made two measurements
the first was the stockfish evaluation
after jan's 15th move and the second was
the stockfish evaluation and i used
stockfish 15 the latest version at a
high depth of 30.
the second measurement was the stockfish
evaluation at move 30. so stockfish eval
move 15 stockfish eval move 30 what i
was trying to determine is
you know
were most of yon's victories really do
to the opening and due to an advantage
that he accrued in the opening and then
extended through the middle game or
were most of jan's victories due to his
play
early in the middle game or was it
neither you know were most of jan's wins
kind of grind the wins that occurred
later in the game
then i was
i told myself wait a second before i
even get to those stats i need to
determine what the average game length
of yan's games was and i need to compare
it to the other competitors because
that's going to tell us a lot
about how yon's games actually
transpired and where most of the winning
happened so
without further ado
let's delve into the stats and here is
the bar graph that i built to show
uh the average length of each
competitor's participants games
so here you have it you can see on the
on the x-axis the names of the players
with nepo first this is an order of
tournament standings
so ding is next for job of third and so
on and on the y-axis you see the average
game length so
what you should notice that this should
immediately jump out at you just look at
the disparity between yon's average game
length and the game lengths of the rest
of the field the entire rest of the
field 35.1 was john's average game
length and you might say well that was
skewed by a quick draw that he had
against nakamura well not really because
most of the players had at least one
relatively quick draw so that's kind of
a non-factor it was not a fluke caused
by one game but rather almost every one
of yon's games was essentially under 40
moves compare that even to the second
place finisher ding
48.6 fabiana carrana 51.1 farouza 50.2
so what does this tell us what does this
mean well this immediately told me two
things the first is something i observed
as i was commentating the event in
madrid which is that jan seems a whole
heck of a lot less tired than a lot of
the other players you could see that in
the interviews you could just almost
sense it from his body language and i
feel like that should be attributed in
large part to simply the fact that his
games weren't taking uh as long of a
time
but the second thing that this told me
was that jan was winning most of his
games early in the middle game i mean
some of his games weren't even lasting
past 35 moves and i'm not just talking
about draws i mean his wins were really
really short his wins were usually
between uh 30 and 40 moves
in length and
then i said well okay but the fact that
let's say ding has an average game like
the 48.6
won't doesn't necessarily mean
that all of ding's wins were that long
and so what i decided to do then was go
back to my initial question just let me
look at yan's move 15 average evaluation
and let me compare it to the average
evaluation on move 15 of dings games and
here's what i found let me close this
graph
and
uh show you this one and i'd like to
give a shout out to d code i'll put the
link in the description for
uh an excellent website and the ability
for a caveman like me to build a
decently readable uh point graph
so what you can see here is the legend
indicates the blue dots are the move 15
evaluations of nepo the red dots are
the move 15 evaluations of ding and the
way that i constructed this is the ones
above the positive values are
essentially when
either nepo or deng were better and the
negative values so minus 0.5 minus 1 or
when nepo or ding were worse
and what you should see here shouldn't
particularly there's nothing that really
jumped out at me what i saw is that
almost in every game
uh the position after move 15 was within
the range of equality for both nepo and
ding now you can see a bit of an outlier
in round four
uh from nepo
you can see small outliers on the other
end of the coin for ding it was slightly
worse uh in round six for example but
you can also notice that nepo was quite
a bit worse
uh in in the final round so
uh so so there's nothing here that that
that screamed to me
that you know the nepo
um
that nepa was winning like all of his
games in the opening in fact i did this
comparison for some of the other players
what i found was largely the same nobody
won or lost this tournament on the basis
of their opening moves not a surprise
because opening preparation has reached
sort of an all-time high
but let's transition to the same graph
move evaluation after move 30
and here's what we find let's close this
one
and open this one and let this graph
sink in for just a second same
measurements same legend blue as nepo
red is ding just look at the disparity
in the move 30 stockish evaluations i
mean this is just crazy now round one
nepo is facing ding so the evaluation is
symmetrically good or bad by move 30
nepo is essentially delivering checkmate
and uh
ding lost a game under 30 moves to
timurajabav in round 12 and the way that
i indicated that was by giving giving
him an overwhelmingly negative
evaluation you can see round 12 that was
against timur jabba so nepo doesn't have
a single game
where the evaluation is below negative
three he's got only one game only one
game out of 14. just think about that
for a second where he is worse on move
30
and that was his second round game
against fabiano caruana and we'll get to
that game uh when we do
our sort of main part of the video where
we actually analyze uh the games that
allowed nepo to win the tournament but
this is an amazing measurement because
ding was in second place and he's got a
ton of games where he's either slightly
worse he's got two games where he's
completely lost or already having
resigned
by move 30
and he's got a ton of games that are in
the range of equality when whereas nepo
has four or five games that are either
completely winning for him you can see
the plus five
in round four
uh and the plus five in round four was
against ali raza faruja you can see uh
plus 2.5 and round six so without
beating a dead horse
you can see just how unbelievably
different
uh nepo's move 30 graph
uh is to dings and even the games that
ding won when i investigated them like
the game against duda which was
essentially equal by move 30 they were
long grind out wins in equal or
semi-equal end games whereas nepo's wins
were straight out of the gate and
something happened between move 15 and
move 30 in nepo's games that didn't
happen in the same stretch of moves for
anybody else in the tournament i
produced a bunch of other graphs a bunch
of other comparative graphs and found
much the same thing this has to do of
course with average move length but for
every competitor even their wins mostly
didn't occur between move 15 and 30. so
we know what we have to do we have to
investigate all five of nepo's wins and
see exactly what is it that he did
between move 15 and move 30 that caused
so many of his incredibly strong
opponents to collapse
and without further ado let us begin our
second
part of the investigation and you could
argue that this is the fun part this is
where we actually look at the chess
okay let me switch scenes here
there we are
and let's begin with nepo's round one
victory against dingley ren this kicked
off the tournament in positive fashion
now we joined the battle on move 17 and
we will not be looking at each game in
its entirety that would be way too long
of a video so we will be looking only at
the sort of pertinent
and critical stretches kind of like
scientists you know trying to figure out
the root cause of something
so it's move 17 and in this position
dingley round who's playing white plays
the move knight a4
so he essentially offers a trade of dark
squared bishops and nepo spent about 20
minutes in this position deciding
whether to
trade the bishops or to do something
else and that's something else
my guess is was the bishop sacrifice on
h4 trying to get to this
relatively weak white king because if
you look at this position everything
about the viking is safe except the fact
that there's this pawn on h4 that's kind
of a hook which black can attack either
with g7 g5 as we'll see later or with a
bishop sack on h4
but i looked at this pretty carefully
and so did nepo
and my guess is that he found that after
takes takes white has this move f3 to
create a little bit of a little bit of
luft for the king on f2 and this is a
highly inconclusive
wild chaotic position that just didn't
uh particularly appeal to young the
engine evaluation here at a high depth
is approximately equal white goes queen
c3 and builds a pretty scary battery
against the g7 pawn
so after a very very long period of
thought
yah decides to go for the bishop trade
and this leads me to the first sort of
very important point about the way that
nepal played in the early middle game he
forced his opponents to make a ton of
decisions so what we'll see in a lot of
these games that nepal played these
moves which are pretty open-ended they
forced his opponent to decide between
you know sometimes two sometimes four
different candidate moves and the stakes
of his opponent's decision always turned
out to be high his opponents
who recently transitioned from an
opening that they were familiar with
just weren't quite capable weren't quite
ready to make decisions of that
importance and watch how quickly ding
collapses when faced with a series of
these types of decisions so the first
thing he does after less than two
minutes is he takes back with the knight
that looks like a completely reasonable
move i mean what kind of madman wouldn't
take back with a knight and try to get
this knight activated through the center
well turns out that knight takes b2 is a
serious step in the wrong direction it
isn't the decisive mistake but queen
takes b2 would have been a lot better
now you might ask well why on earth is
that the case there's two main reasons
the first is that queen takes b2 already
creates a big positional threat and that
is the move b5
why is b5 dangerous well let's say that
black does kind of like what nepo did in
the game tries to lift the rook to the h
file and then proceed by crashing
through with g5 but white is already
ready to play b5 and after cb5 queen b5
in black swole position collapses here
the queen x-rays the bishop attacks b7
and this just looks absolutely terrible
you can't play b6 because you drop the
knight on a6 if you play something like
rogue b8 then white can centralize the
rook with rook d1 and there's queen
takes b7 now as a threat so this is not
appetizing in the least so what black
would have had to do is drop this knight
back to c7 which nepo ends up doing
anyway to stop b5 but this is where the
position of the knight on a4 is
justified white can start with a neutral
move like rook after one but the point
is that black now has a very very hard
time lifting the rook to e6 because of
this move knight c5 followed by knight
takes b7
and the queen on b2 is also well placed
because in the event of rook h6 knight
b7 g5 black just goes this is sparta
tries to crash through the queen jumps
into e5 forking the two minor pieces and
black is not in time to crash through
down the h file so
uh so
this would have been a far more prudent
decision after which i think white is
actually slightly better
but instead think takes on b2 with the
knight
nepo patiently guides his knight to the
center with knight c7
ding plays knight c4 that was his entire
idea
which nepo parries with the move rookie
six
and ding now kind of realized the
gravity of the situation he spent over
10 minutes
on his next move
as it turns out his situation continues
to get worse for the next couple of
moves he plays the move rook ft-1
totally sensible he centralizes the rook
entirely fine that move is good
but after knight d5
he either underestimated the gravity of
the situation or he panicked because he
realized that nepo is actually very very
close to playing the move g5 i mean he's
basically two moves away rook h6 and g5
and the moment the age file opens i mean
the situation becomes dire you could get
checkmated here in the span of a couple
of moves and in only 30 seconds ding
plays an incredibly panicky move he
places rook to d4 which creates an empty
threat that's not even a threat and
allows nepo to more carefully prepare
the move g5 after rook d4 white is
already quite a bit worse and then after
the next move white is totally lost ding
had to go b5 he had to crash through on
the queen side create some counter play
and here the position remains very
complex but after rook d8 or rook d4
rather nepo could have played the
immediate g5 which was better according
to the engine but instead he quickly
plays h6 he wants to prepare g5 with a
pawn and recapture with a pawn and then
get his rook to h6 and this is where
ding absolutely panicked he had only one
idea that would have saved the game and
this idea is not easy to find now it's
not bishop takes c4 because of rook
takes c4 rook takes e4 and now the
knight drops back to f6 attacking the
rook twice
now white doesn't seem to have a problem
defending the rook while he can play
knight d6 but then nepo takes on e4
he would have played rook e8 tying the
knight down even further again seems
like no problem white plays f3 but loose
pieces drop off and here the brilliant
conclusion of the line takes on e4
queen swings to e5
double attack against the rook of the
pawn white's entire king side collapses
the game is simply over this might have
been what ding was aiming for initially
we will never know but the only saving
resource would have been actually to
double rooks on d1 which sounds like
what are you preparing and this knight
is protected by a pawn and that's
exactly the point after g5 white can
sacrifice the exchange on d5 and it
turns out that after white takes on d5
he's got pretty significant compensation
for the exchange if the bishop moves
away then you will not be able to take
on h4 because your queen is pinned but
if you play g takes h4 another detail
that ding might have missed white has
the move knight d6 attacking the bishop
a second time essentially forcing black
to give the exchange back and leading to
a
very complicated position that the
engine assesses as equal
but yet again notice that nepo is
putting his opponent in a situation
where he has to find these super complex
ideas and where he has
four or five candidate moves that need
to be calculated at this point ding was
already in time pressure and he panics
completely with the move queen d2 maybe
intending an exchange sacrifice but nepo
says hey i'm not in a hurry to play g5
you have abandoned the e4 pawn so i'm
just gonna double my rooks on e8 and
after king h2 which makes matters even
worse again nepo doesn't rush with g5 he
improves his bishop attacking the e2
pawn
gets his rook to f6 attacking the f2
pawn and after king g1 he finally
strikes with g5 and at this point the
attack has reached unstoppable levels
ding has managed to do absolutely
nothing on the queen side and
he finally is attacking b7 which he took
but it is way way too late to do
anything the exchange stack is also no
longer applicable because the queen
defends d5 and nepo went on to finish
the attack in excellent fashion and only
a couple of moves
so that was nepo's first win
now we go to nepo's second win against
ali reza faruga and this was
i believe round four but i could uh
let me check that really fast i should
have had this information at hand
yes this was round four
so the opening was a very theoretical
night or sicilian and this variation of
the naidorf
that you see on the board has been
around for well over a decade probably
even more than two decades and
for many many years in this position
uh black players automatically went a4
this was the move and it led to this
very very sharp line white goes knight
d4
you don't have to pay much attention to
this this is beyond the scope of the
video but the long story short is that
there was a super theoretical position
and eventually it started to
turn out that white has a bit of an
advantage in these positions new ideas
were found
and black has been struggling in the
slide ever since so alireza decided to
revive the line by playing the move
bishop e6 to c4 which is probably what
you would play if you had been seeing
this position for a first time
now for a long time this this move had
been considered
uh dubious because of the response uh
knight g3
but uh ali reza had analyzed this
position with some very strong engines
and you you see this pretty often these
days where these lines that had long
been considered refuted are now actually
getting revived by the strongest new
engines but instead nepo demonstrating
stellar preparation goes king b1 which
is also a very popular move and has been
played quite a few times in this
position this is still preparation for
both players a4 and knight bc1 which is
of course the idea of king b1 you're
opening up for yourself a square for the
knight
ali reza whoops alireza strikes in the
center with the move d5 another typical
idea in this line to get this knight out
of the incredibly passive v8 square and
now nepo plays f6 blasting through on
the king's side he only spent two
minutes on this move which tells me that
this is still
preparation it's also still preparation
for ali reza she takes f6 instantly this
has occurred by the way before g takes
f6 and this is the novelty
the previous two or three times if this
position had occurred
white played the immediate knight g3 so
nepo takes on f6 it's an incredibly
complicated position and this is where
the magic happens so nepo plays the move
knight she
and
what is so difficult about managing this
position for black first of all i think
it was a bad practical choice for
alireza just look at the state of
black's king look at the state of
black's pieces this is not an easy
position to play no matter how
how deeply you've analyzed it with an
engine
the second thing to realize that white's
king is incredibly safe this knight on
c1 is a great defender black can't just
throw everything at white with a move
like b3 because well even the simple cb3
ab3 and even a3 is okay here but
a move like bishop h6 is even scarier if
black takes on a2 no problemo at all the
king just tucks itself away on a1
but the problem here is that white has a
hidden threat
well what is the hidden threat let's say
that black plays a random move just to
illustrate this after rook b8 for
example
white actually wants to take on c4
trade queens and you might say doesn't
that counteract the entire idea of the
line and aren't we down a pawn but after
bishop takes the eight maybe you can
pause the video and quickly figure out
what the final move of the sequence is
well hopefully you're able to see that
the rook on f8 has no squares white
jumps into c5 and simply wins the
exchange
so if we rewind for a second this is a
pretty serious threat
and what's incredibly devious about this
that there seems to be a very obvious
way to deal with the threat well
if white wants to take on c4 then why
don't we just take the bishop on f1 to
unburden ourselves from this problem
now before we go on it's important to
point out that there is also a second
threat with the same idea of trapping
this rook the move i mentioned earlier
bishop h6 is a very very scary prospect
because the rook on f8 is again going to
be trapped so it seems very logical that
black can defend against both of these
ideas by shifting the king to h8 and
opening up an escape square for the rook
that seems totally reasonable but here's
the question do you do it before bishop
takes f1
or after bishop takes up one do you take
the bishop first or do you play the
immediate king h8
this is a wildly difficult decision one
that alireza spent
well over 10 minutes on over 20 minutes
on he spent something on the order of 25
minutes on his next move
but this is what nepa was doing all
tournament putting his opponent in a
situation where he has to make a
difficult decision right out of the
opening if i had to explain nepo's
success in a nutshell he did that every
single game that he won
and furuja ends up making the wrong
choice the correct move would have been
the immediate king h8 the only way to
keep the balance now what i think
galireza was afraid of i think he was
afraid that nepa would still end up
trading everything on d8 rook d8 rook d8
uh and in this position
he would play the move not rotate steed
but knight f5 attacking the bishop the
bishop is actually now suddenly in quite
a bit of trouble but if you keep
calculating it turns out that black has
the calm bishop d6
and even bishop g5 doesn't do as much as
it appears the bishop drops back to c7
everything is fine black is up upon
white's got full compensation in the
form of active pieces but not more than
that the position remains dynamically
balanced
according to the engine
but
back to knight g3 alireza decides i'm
going to take i'm going to go a3 first
with the obvious threat of a takes b3 so
nepo has to respond to that he plays b3
and now i'm going to calmly defend
against bishop h6 with the move king h8
now that looks completely fine in
practice
in principle
but not in practice because the one
thing that i think ali reza kind of
underestimated is that nepo can now take
the pawn on d5
and the whole idea of this pawn
sacrifice in the first place is to free
up a very nice square for the knight
which is exactly what alireza does he
plays the move knight d6
and this turns out actually to be the
decisive mistake black's position is
already very very bad the only way to
keep chances alive would have been to
shift the queen to c7 but here white has
the incredibly strong exchange sacrifice
rook takes f6 you can analyze this on
your own
all the rest of play plays 96 and nepo
he thinks for a bit he thinks for right
about three minutes and he says ali raza
thank you very much for your main pawn
the b4 pawn which is one of black's main
attackers because it protects the c3
pawn
alireza must have relied on the fact
that there will be a discovered attack
against the queen but there isn't a
discovered attack against the queen
there isn't even anything remotely
dangerous that black can do
knight e4 no problem at all let me throw
this pawn onto d6 bishop d6 rook d6 and
black's position collapses knight t6
bishop g5 with a devastating pin
okay
what else can black try knight f5 same
exact thing
white plays d6 and even the simple queen
e1 leads to a winning position this is a
complete paper tiger which ali reza had
clearly
failed to notice but it doesn't stop
there reza plays rook c8 to prepare the
move knight c4 he tries to make
something out of nothing and nepo has a
lot of ways to keep the advantage but
the second thing he did was
unbelievable precision in this stretch
from move 15 to move 30. he generally
found the correct move every time that
there was a a move that led to a very
significant evaluation and there was a
drop off between the first best move and
the second best move nepo almost always
found the top move he notices that the
pawn on e5 is actually a very big
weakness you won't think of it that way
or who cares about that pawn and how
does white even attack it well here's
how bishop b6 attacking the queen and
queen b4 to e1 played in 45 seconds no
less
attacking the pawn and e5 and you can't
defend it you can't defend the pawn the
only thing you can do is play e4
but that yields the devastating long
diagonal after bishop d4 black can
resign in fact black can already resign
here because this attack on the pawn
coupled with the fact that black's king
is unbelievably weak leads to a totally
losing position varusha played rook b8
nepo calmly brings the bishop back to a5
and the only way that faruga found to
defend the pawn is knight c4 right using
the pin but what does that do well we
already know that anytime you move the
knight away from d6 white has the
possibility of ripping open everything
with the move d6 nepo plays it without
hesitation after bishop d8 bishop c3 the
game is essentially over the knight
comes out to d3 and after knight d5 nepo
finishes things up with knight f4
forcing the exchange of knights and
using the pin a very elegant move and
the game lasted uh only seven more moves
black's position is completely in
shambles
and uh the game is essentially over so
once again the mo in this game was to
force ali reza to make a difficult
decision immediately out of the opening
now we go to our third victory against
jan shistop duda
against yanchez abdullah in round six
so nepo in this game decided to play a
king's indian attack
and it led to a very unbalanced position
with two bishops for each side so this
is the position on the board
um
after duda's 14th move
now a lot of people here would say okay
well the pawn on e5 is kind of a
weakness it's not hanging right it's not
technically hanging because the bishop
on c5
is going to be hanging in return
but i think a lot of people play move
like bishop c3 here let me let me
protect this pawn just in case
the problem here is that black will go
rook ada and let's not forget the black
is a pretty impressive pawn center which
he can use to shove this d-pawn down the
board and neither of white's bishops is
particularly impressive uh where they
sit so nepo decides that his biggest
advantage lies in exploiting his
kingside pawn majority and that's
exactly what he does he plays the move
g4
using some small tactics if queen takes
e5 check he covers with tempo and wins
one of the bishops
and after bishop g6 nepo fearlessly
advances his f1 to f4 threatening the
move f5
now this is not the point at which duda
has a big decision to make at this point
black's move is pretty clear he's got to
create some lift
now nepo spends about 20 minutes
and i love that he does this because he
did it at strategic moments throughout
the tournament he's a pretty fast player
but he still spent time when he when he
had to and there's no doubt in my mind
that he was considering the move f5 very
seriously and perhaps you're wondering
why you wouldn't play that novel the
problem is that after bishop h7 bishop
f4 you got to defend the pawn
yes the black bishop is very poorly
placed at the moment but so is the pawn
on e5 and black can shift the bishop
around to c7 and attack this pawn with
everything that he's got the rook the
bishop the queen and white is gonna have
a very very hard time defending that
pawn if you say all right i'm gonna
bring my queen over to defend it well
after queen g3
g5 is a very strong move here by the way
but even after rook 88 bl white is
defenseless against the threat of bishop
takes c5 and besides f5 would basically
force black to find the correct moves
instead look at what nepo does he plays
the move queen to e1
now the intention of this move is pretty
clear he's trying to get his queen to g3
but why is he doing that well that's
exactly what tripped duda up duda plays
rook field piling up on the e5 upon
discouraging f5
nepo goes queen g3 and it is at this
point that black has a huge decision to
make
and it actually doesn't seem like black
has such a big decision to make it seems
pretty obvious what what black should do
well if nepo brought his queen to g3
reasons do not that means he wants to
play f5 and maybe even f6 that's not
something that i could allow
so here's what i'm going to do says dude
i'm going to bring this bishop back to
h7 preliminarily which is a very smart
looking idea because if white plays f5
well you still can't take on e5 because
you're going to drop the bishop as we
discussed but what you can do is play
bishop to d4 forking the b2 and e5 bonds
less important is the fact that black
attacks this pawn more important is the
fact that white cannot defend e5
and duda thought that he had everything
covered
but it turns out that nepo had tricked
him and nepo's idea was never actually
to play f5 or it was but that wasn't his
main idea
his main idea was to play h4
okay
well what h4 why h4 what is he trying to
do
well what he's trying to do is actually
push the pawn up to g5 not to f5 in
order to shatter black's king position
duda totally oblivious to that goes rook
88 he thinks he's out of the woods he
thinks he's totally out of the woods but
suddenly nepo advances not the f pawn as
i still think judah was expecting this
but the g-pawn g4 g5
the whole point is that if black keeps
the king's side dried up with h5 now
white plays out five
now y plays f5 and if you play bishop d4
much like in the game the pawns
overwhelm the black pieces e6 f takes c6
and g6 simply traps the bishop on h7
so once again nepo was forcing his
opponent to make a decision but without
duda even realizing that there was a
decision to be made and the decision to
be made is how do we discourage the move
g5
there was a hidden threat that nepo had
made he had lulled duda into a sense of
security into thinking hey i've stopped
white from playing f5 i'm safe on the
king's side
and so duda makes a general improving
move forgetting that nepo's idea is
actually to first play g5 and then to
play a five in fact there was only one
way only one reliable way to take the
sting out of the move h5 you had to play
bishop d4
and the point is that if white plays g5
you don't take the pawn on b2 that would
be way too greedy on account of g takes
h6
but you simply play h5 and bishop d4 is
a prophylactic move now white can't play
f5 because the bishop takes e5 and you
don't have the time to go g6
so after bishop d4 most likely nepo
would have gone bishop c3
now you trade bishops and now once again
it is critically important for black to
put a stop to white's king side pressure
and play the fearless g7 g5 not an easy
move to make but the only move which
leads to full-fledged dynamic equality
the position remains incredibly sharp
but black can actually try to turn the
king side around to his favor with the
move king g7 followed by rook 8 chain
and it turns out that white's king is
actually not out of the woods
but duda didn't find that and instead he
played the move rook 88 and nepo once
again
as i said in the previous game any time
he had the opportunity to act precisely
in order to gain an advantage he did
that he almost never missed those
opportunities where the top engine move
there was a big difference in the top
engine move and the second engine
movement he plays perfectly in the next
stretch he goes g5
duda has nothing better to do than to
take on g5 but now he has sprung a leak
and not only has he sprung a leak but
after bishop before nepo trades and
plays f5 and once again the threat of g6
gives f5 new life and duda saw nothing
better than to give away the bishop he
takes on b2 he gets a bunch of pawns for
it that's true but he loses the bishop
in the middle game and that was not a
loss that he
uh that he could
survive now this was maybe the last
chance for duda to gain serious drawing
chances he had to take this pawn which
is not an easy thing to do putting the
king in harm's way the point is that
after rook b1 you drop the queen back to
e5 and you force the queen trade instead
duda kind of automatically played king
h8 in less than two minutes
and after rook b1
it turns out that you don't have the
time to go queen e5 anymore because
after rook takes b7 you're going to have
to waste a move to take this pawn on h7
right you're gonna have to take it
eventually or white's gonna defend it
and it's gonna win the game so with
queen e5 out of the question duda has to
keep the queens on the board but the
side with the extra minor piece
obviously favors in that
uh in that event and nepo ends up
winning this game pretty smoothly in
only seven more moves duda had a couple
of chances but after rook takes up 5
another brilliant tactic you can't take
because you get mated the white king is
perfectly safe surrounded as it is by
this cocoon of pieces which are also
attacking
then he brings the rook to f7
threatening rook ffa check he covers the
check by duda
and then all of a sudden he swings the
rook to g5 and the pressure on g7 has
gotten totally unbearable and at the end
of the game what's ironic is that duda
never managed never managed to capture
the pawn on h7 and it actually ends up
winning the game without that pawn
white's attack would have still been
devastating but not quite as devastating
on the next move nepo is going to take
on g7 and go riccigana duda
with almost no time left on his clock
resigned the game
now game four
was a particularly win number four i
apologize was a particularly fascinating
game this was round seven
and it's fascinating about it is that uh
i think the reason for nepo's win was
largely overlooked by by the
commentators
um and by people analyzing the game they
played a petrov and eppo has been
playing the petrov pretty much
exclusively uh
starting from his first world
championship match against magnus
now they reached a position which is
incredibly popular
and there's a lot of popular moves in
this position c takes d5
knight c3
rookie one
and richard report decides to make an
exceedingly rare move which has
approximately 15 games in the database
he plays queen to b3
and even by the standards of these top
gm's and move like queen b3 i would not
bat an eye if nepo didn't remember his
analysis or even didn't know the move
but he did and not only did he know the
move but he responds with an even more
rare continuation the main move in this
position this has been played by
grandmasters knight a6
but i looked at this carefully and i
think this is what richard report was
hoping for after knight c3 white gets a
very pleasant position i feel like these
structures are always in white's favor
plus the knight on a6 is a little bit
awkward the engine it gives white a
pretty stable edge
instead nepo fearlessly brings his
bishop out to g4 sacrificing the pawn on
b7 and aiming for a rapid-fire king-side
attack he wants to take this knight out
of the equation
and on queen takes b7 he would have done
just that this is unthinkable because
after gfb queen h4 the attack
grows totally unbearable but report knew
this as well
and richard report keeps splitting out
moves he takes the knight he brings the
knight to g5
nepo blitzes out moves as well bishop
back to e7 opening up the attack on d4
they both take each other's center pawns
and richard report finally takes on b7
of the queen
they're still blitzing out these moves
now the craziest thing about this this
position occurred for the first time in
1928 that's how long it's been known in
a correspondence game to be fair where
black was the czech
czech republic czechoslovakia
correspondents champion
after queen takes e4 queen takes a8
modern computers immediately give the
move that nepo played
but the czech correspondent champion
actually made a completely viable move
as well and a move later he demonstrated
the idea that nepo uses in on this move
that game continued bishop d6 queen
takes a7 and now bishop g4 to h3
and the point is that after g takes h3
he swings the queen up to e5
this was 1928
and no computers no nothing just you had
the time to think about it because it
was a correspondence game and the point
is that after f4 black delivers the
inter mezzo and then another intermezzo
and it's either checkmate or black wins
the queen so white has to allow queen
takes h2 the position is incredibly
complicated and i don't think that white
is even better here either but nepo
decides to go for the immediate drop
bishop h3 straight away
g takes h3 and now our repetition of
moves check check
check check now richard report goes for
it he plays f3 which is fine
now queen d3
and this is the moment at which report
goes crazy
now
the civilized move king g2 queen g6 king
h1 queen d3 you have no way to defend
the rook you have to go king g2 or wait
a second do you that's what report
thought he said no no no i don't have to
go for the draw i can defend my rook
with my knight
and it's not that he missed nepo's next
move which is queen d7 the queen
suddenly swings back to d7 preparing the
unstoppable knight a6 which will trap
white's queen and force white to give
that queen away for nepo's second rook
now it's not that report didn't see that
he obviously saw that but by his own
admission he completely mis-evaluated
the resulting position
the resulting position which happens
after 94 knight a6 queen f8 bishop f8 is
actually much much better for black
borderline winning and i feel like a lot
of commentators
um and people look at this game were
just like what is report thinking it's
obvious that black is much better who
was actually not that obvious that black
is much better here the the reason isn't
anything having to do with material
white is up material counting white has
two rooks in a pawn for the queen so
from a material standpoint report's
decision makes a lot of sense
it doesn't make a lot of sense from the
perspective of king's safety white's
king is going to be permanently unsafe
the second thing to note is that white
is going to lose one of the pawns back
the h3 pawn is a sitting duck if you
push it then you allow something even
worse to happen the queen jumps into d4
and you're gonna end up losing a much
more valuable pawn so report decided to
go for the lesser evil and he gave up
the h3 pawn in order to bring his pieces
into the game nepo makes them lift with
h6 and after bishop g3 once again a
moment has arrived has arisen where in
order to solidify a big advantage yonder
palmishi has to find the best move the
second best move is not nearly as good
and yet again he does he plays knight a6
to c5
essentially forcing white either to
trade knights or to allow blacks knight
to jump into the game by retreating to
e6 and then advancing toward the king
side either to f4 or to g5
now richard probably should have traded
knights here but this position is
terrible white can't move
the pawn on f3 is incredibly weak black
has a simple idea of advancing the h1
and dislodging the bishop which means
that this rook is basically paralyzed
and this is you know i would avoid this
with a 10-foot pole this was richard
reports uh lesser evil
but the funny thing is if you're rewind
rook fe1 actually or bishop g3 rather
was the big mistake it was the decisive
mistake in my opinion he had to play the
relatively inhuman move a3 and now that
i've shown you this line i hope you
you're able to figure out why a3 is
required it's required because white
needs to get rid of this bishop b4
forces the bishop off the diagonal after
bishop d4 you drop the bishop back to g3
and black's bishop is a lot less stable
on d4 while it's hanging it's defended
indirectly but eventually white will be
able to move the f rook away and force
the bishop off of this diagonal giving
white a little bit more freedom from his
pieces for his pieces but all of that is
a bit of a moot point because nepo is
already much better after rook fe1 he
again correctly brings the knight back
to e6 and advances the pawn to h5 later
he brought it to h4 and white's position
is getting shattered the knight is
jumping into f4
and richard report defended he defended
resiliently but in 10 more moves it was
game over and look look at how nepo uses
his knight to hit report where it hurts
attacking f3 attacking e4 the queen and
knight combo is the most dangerous
tandem in all of chess and nepo
illustrated that with this swim now you
might ask what was the reason behind
this one did he get a little bit
fortunate absolutely he got fortunate in
that richard report decided to test him
on a line uh that he knew but
last time i checked that's not luck
that's diligence that's incredibly good
preparation that's a good job expecting
surprises and leaving no stone unturned
looking at a very rare move and not just
settling for what people had played
previously but actually looking with a
very strong engine and finding bishop g4
and what did i say earlier every game
that nepo won was at least partially due
to a situation in which he forced his
opponent to make inconvenient decisions
well where was that inconvenient
decision here well it was that very
decision report made to decline the draw
because think of it he's playing with
the white pieces nepo at this point is
leading the tournament richard report
wants to be the hero he doesn't want to
admit that his preparation has failed
and he wants to make nepo work he wants
to give himself a chance and those
considerations make it a lot more likely
that you will look at a certain position
with rose-colored glasses he'll say well
i've got two rooks for the queen my king
is okay it's defended by a bunch of
pieces and a superficial assessment of
the position report only spent two
minutes of three minutes or so on knight
d2 itself
all of that stems from the fact that
nepal put him in that position where hey
you know that demon is calling your name
right you can go for the win here it's
not too much risk you've got two rooks
once again report makes the wrong
decision and loses the game
and the final victory was uh a game that
is now very famous against ali reza
farousha in round 11 that was followed
by three draws clinching the tournament
and in round 11 i resin the night before
he had played a bullet match very
responsibly against someone who shall go
unnamed
but
once again it was a petrov nepo has the
black pieces so we'll flip the board and
uh i don't think i flipped the board in
the last game but that's okay
so the following position occurs once
again after ali reza's 15th move he goes
king h1
nepo brings his rook into the game with
rook aca that's a prophylactic move it's
a very astute one and it's prophylaxis
against f4 which would be a very nasty
move you don't want to bring your knight
back to g6 that knight is very very very
poorly positioned instead you want to go
knight c4
and if white continues tossing the
knight around with v3 you sh you jump
into e3 little tactics little tactics or
take c3 and after bishop f2 the position
is tremendously complex i let the engine
sit here it's giving a tiny minuscule
edge for white this knight on d4 is very
nicely placed but conversely the pawn on
d5 is a major weakness so
this is what alireza should have gone
for but
looking at this position it's not easy
to determine that white is not worse in
a position after knight e3
and yet again
did nepo know that only restaurant had
the bullet session the night before was
probably tired
no probably he didn't but he reached a
position in which all of the pieces are
still on the board and he knows that
alireza is having a bad tournament and
so in a situation like this he knows
that alireza is likely to make a hasty
or otherwise extreme rash impulsive
decision and that's exactly what alireza
does in this highly complicated position
of the reza spence a little bit over 10
minutes and plays g2 g4 trying to catch
nepo off guard and shove this pawn down
to g5
nepo doesn't take very long to say no no
no you're not doing that he goes h6
ali reza insists he plays h4
and yet again i've traced two patterns
that have been responsible for nepo's
wins in the early middle game the first
forcing his opponent to make in
convenient decisions but the second
almost always reacting correctly when
the difference between the first move
and the second was big
and that is the case for nepo's next
couple of moves he plays the com rook
feat
preparing this rook is going to be a
very very important piece
while he reza continues with his plan
takes takes knight f6 to h5 fearlessly
dragging the knight to the rim because
it's got access to the g3 scar alireza
had been aiming for this position after
king g2 if you look at it carefully you
might say well white is threatening to
play f4 attacking both knights at the
same time there isn't much that black
can do about that i think a lot of
people would be tempted to play g6 here
but after f4 knight c4 white takes on h5
anyway and how the heck do we evaluate
this position white can't take on h5
but
you know white can play a bunch of
different moves even 96
is a very interesting idea followed by
queen takes h5 black's king is in a lot
of trouble here
and the position remains very very
complex a lot of people would do that
a lot of people would probably jump to
c4 immediately and then transpose into
that line but not yonder pomnishing he
takes 10 minutes and he finds yet again
the most accurate move knight e5 to g6
preparing a brilliant knight sacrifice
ali reza has no choice but to play out
for otherwise black's knight jumps into
f4 with disastrous effects
but knight takes f4 is a sacrifice that
i'm hoping you remember and is seared
into your memory because this is the
candidate's winning sequence queen takes
me to bang striking at the queen tied
all of white's pieces are collapsing
knight is hanging bishop is hanging king
is weak alireza despite resilient
defense is unable to keep himself in the
game rooksy for another brilliant move
attacking the knight on d4 using the pin
and uh bishop takes g5
queen side king side queen side king
side strike strike strike bishop takes
g5 if you take with a knight then you
give up e3 if you take with the bishop
then you give up e4 and then d4 is going
to fall because you can't move the
knight the other bishop hangs all of ali
reza's minor pieces are in trouble
and i can analyze this for another 20
minutes rook takes d4 is another
brilliant move but the upshot is that on
the heels of 10 or 15 accurate moves
nepa reached an end game which
practically speaking is completely
winning black's got four past pawns
white's king is still incredibly weak
and white's pieces are scattered all
around the board nepo uh farouza rather
could have still defended if he was an
engine but
sometimes he is but most of the time
he's not and it didn't take nepo very
long first to trap the knight drag the
rook into the game with rookie 3
threatening bishop h3 and i'm going very
quickly here because this is outside the
scope of what we're talking about this
is already move 34. the game does not
last past move 35 bishop e4 check is
crushing because either alireza gets
checkmated or he allows bishop takes d5
with a fork against the rook and the
knight and nepo finished the game with a
lot of time
and those ladies and gentlemen were
nepo's five victories in the candidates
the rest of the games ended in draws he
was only flat out losing
well one and a half times against
fabiano caruana in round two but the
position was incredibly complex and then
against ikaru nakamura where the
position was also incredibly complex and
finding the winning path involved
something that nepo had been doing a lot
more consistently than his opponents
finding the correct move in critical
moments in moments where if you didn't
find the correct move the evaluation
dropped precipitously everybody in this
tournament in the candidates
was able to find good moves a lot of the
time nepo was the only one who found
those good moves with incredible
consistency in the early middle game
that is where he won all five of his
games in between moves 15
and 30. and in conclusion let's go back
for a second to our graphic our move 30
graphic just look at the difference
between nepo and ding the second place
finisher you can imagine how much more
drastic this graph looks when you
compare nepo to the other player so both
in terms of game length and in terms of
this measurement we can see that where
nepo's greatest strength lay this
tournament was in his ability to win the
game early in the middle game his
opponent had just transitioned from the
opening and was still somewhat
unprepared to make big decisions nepal
forced his opponents to make big
decisions and then when he was
confronted with big decisions himself he
almost always made the right one and
responded very very accurately to his
opponent's biggest mistakes
there's a lot more to talk about i could
make 10 videos on nepo's candidate's
performance and i know that a lot of
this analysis was a little bit rushed
but i'm hoping that this gives you a
somewhat better sense i'm getting this
question a lot on stream you know why
does
one super gm win a tournament over
another how does that happen i'm hoping
that i was able to shine at least a very
dim light on that question i hope you
enjoyed the stats and the analysis i'd
like to thank you for watching the video
this was a long one but i had a ton of
fun talking about nepal i'd like to
congratulate him one more time and wish
him
the very best of luck in his match
against ding liren
but for now thank you for watching
please feel free to leave questions
in the comments as usual and i will see
you in the next video
[Music]